how many people have the opportunity to
be a world champion at anything we have
the opportunity to do something that no
one else does this isn't played anywhere
else in the world so yeah like it's
serious like we want to win
[Music]
we're here to watch unicycle football
it's football on unicycles
[Music]
we should stick the nfl rules as closely
as possible
says there are a few exceptions because
we're riding a unicycle
we play five on five two receivers a
blocker a center and a quarterback
everything has to be done on a wheel
the second your foot touches the ground
you're done
each team plays 14 games there's 56
regular season games total then wild
card playoffs then playoffs and then the
super bowl every sunday some people have
been doing this for 10 years now
my team the black house we're undefeated
and we're going to be playing the
reigning champs the herons
bulldoze them over bulldozing this game
is very important because we want to
maintain our undefeated status leading
up to the super bowl they're definitely
going for us they're practicing just for
us
i think that a lot of times people come
to this game what shocks them
is the level of play
we're crashing at 15 miles an hour it's
not a joke
some people get seriously injured
most people learn to ride unicycle
because they came and witnessed this
event and they're like i've got to do
this
once you catch that first ball
once you get that first rush once you
hear the crowd scream your name once
that's a feeling you can't get anywhere
else it's almost like a religion church
to us here
there's passion you know it's a show
it's a spectacle
it's also a sport
i've cherished every minute of it
you can't replace it with anything
there's nothing else like it
at all
[Music]
[Music]
there's more to sight than just being
able to see the crowd you can definitely
feel
the atmosphere
there's a vibe in the air there's the
energy in the air there's the sound
it's amazing to hear the fans
especially when we're out of the tunnel
i'm jake wilson i'm the long snapper of
the university of southern california
trojans i'm completely blind i have no
eyes
i went into playing football with the
mentality that i had nothing to lose
long snapping is an art
you definitely have the mechanics but a
lot of it's just feel feeling that ball
coming off your fingertips in a spiral
how hard you're throwing it you know
where you're releasing it just kind of
getting that velocity and that and the
accuracy
life's unfair football is unfair but at
the same time
it's up to you of how far
you want to take yourself
when i was eight months old i was
diagnosed with a rare form of eye cancer
called retinoblastoma
when the doctors found my cancer
it was completely taken over my left eye
so they almost immediately removed my
left eye
from there on you know just a cycle of
you know the cancer coming back then we
fight it with treatments
doctors finally said listen we pretty
much exhausted all all treatment options
the safer option is just you know the
removal of the eye
growing up in the 2000s where coach
carroll was
so dominant with usc it was hard not to
be a usc fan
i always love football i continued to
play flag football my eighth grade year
after losing my sight it was not
anything close
to tackle football
as i entered high school i decided not
to play football for my freshman and
sophomore year it really was something
that i didn't think i could do but
eventually my love for the game really
overcame any doubts and i learned how to
be an asset
there you go
i just love the camaraderie of football
i love being part of the team love
putting on you know just the pads and
the jersey and stuff and
being part of the team was enough just
to get me to try
[Music]
when you see the players get the ball in
their hand for the first time it's a
cross between intrigue and excitement
it's great to see him try and bounce the
ball and to see it actually bounce away
it can make the best of people look
really really silly
the number one sport in australia is
australian rules football
it's basically a cross between rugby and
soccer
and the fans go crazy for it
there's one problem
they don't have enough tall people
so what do they do
they come to the states
[Music]
this combines the usafl combine and we
started this four years ago
basically in a search for for guys six
foot seven and above
[Music]
and these tall american athletes they
don't really need to know a lot about
australia
the home of the kangaroos i think i know
a lot of kangaroos i hear a lot about
kangaroos and spiders and snakes
in selecting these athletes we
predominantly look for guys that are
hungry
most of the participants predominantly
come from basketball
the concept of basketball in terms of
the athlete being in traffic and having
spatial awareness and those sorts of
things
is really transferable to our game
which is good news because less than two
percent of college basketball players
will make it to the pros
the australian football league gives
them another chance to live out their
dreams of being a pro athlete
most of the participants are quite
shocked when they see the game for the
first time
the question is what do the athletes
think of all this
when i got the kind of invite i thought
it was fake actually i thought it was a
scam
the first thing i thought there was a
scam i thought they was contacting the
wrong person actually what is australian
football
skepticism aside how do you teach these
guys a game they never even heard of
before
so the combine kicks off in the early
piece with the physical testing and then
start to build into the skills
the basics of handballing the ability to
see what they're like with their hands
then we can start to get into the more
competitive stuff where they might crash
and bash into each other which they love
that
[Music]
[Applause]
this is mason cox
he played basketball at oklahoma state
two years ago he was just like one of
these guys on the combine
now he's playing professionally in
australia
they can be one of the 22 superstars out
there on an afl team
it's a fantastic opportunity for these
guys to continue their professional
career
okay squad listen up
there's more than one way to end a game
with sports ball
there's the walk off home run
the sudden death gold
the buzzer beater
but within the adrenaline adult psyche
of the american sports fan can any of
them produce a heart attack like a
successful hail mary pass don't answer
that it's rhetorical
why are hail marys special because
they're unicorns since 1975 there's only
been 28 of them in professional football
why because they're almost impossible to
get right to complete a hail mary the
pass needs to be long like thrown from
midfield long with little or no time
remaining on the clock and you need to
be losing and the pass must lead to a
touchdown that results in at least a tie
but preferably a win that is a hail mary
most quarterbacks are likelier to marry
a supermodel than to throw a successful
hail mary in their career exhibit a tom
brady
so how did this play which practically
requires an act of god to come to pass
see what i did there easy with a prayer
[Music]
hail mary full of grace the lord is with
thee
so it's december 28 1975.
50 yards from the end zone but needing a
touchdown to win
cowboys quarterback and devout catholic
roger staubach whispers a hail mary to
himself hell mary full of grace the lord
is with thee and launches a desperation
pass to receiver drew pearson the
cowboys win and the hail mary is
christened forevermore
any questions good now go win me some
ball games
[Applause]
you